was ist hier los warum ist ja alles mit
alu folie bedeckt der fernseher die
lande
die bilder ich habe vor einigen tagen
ein video hochgeladen dem ich eigentlich
nur update mäßig mal nachschauen wollte
was mittlerweile mit dem hilft mir kanal
passiert ist so will ich aber nicht
gerechnet habe ist dass ihr in den
kommentaren unter dem video komplett
ausgerastet seiten davon geschwärmt wie
gut ich und eben wir zusammenpassen und
dass er wieder neuer hilft mir videos
sehen weil deswegen leute habe ich mich
nach reiflicher überlegung schweren
herzens auf die suche nach einem neuen
passenden hilfe mehr video gemacht und
ich kann nur soviel sagen ich bin fündig
geworden allein bis zum teil beendet
eigentlich schon jegliche überlegung die
man als mensch haben kann die videochat
lautet verstrahlt der elektrosmog bild
uns alle umbringen passt ganz gut in die
aktuelle zeit schauen wir rein
man kann gar nie sein leute aber wenn
uns das leben auf dieser welt einst
gelehrt hat dann das hilft mir zwar
grober schmutz ist aber aber dass sehr
viele von diesen stories irgendwo auch
ein funken wahrheit in sich haben und
sich jetzt ihr wahrscheinlichkeit ging
die strahlung oder so es ist alles
elektrosmog gerade handys machen die
größten strahlen überhaupt alles da
gedacht ich wusste gar nicht dass die
strahlen unterschiedlich groß sein
können also schaue mir geht es sehr sehr
kleine strahlung und auf der anderen
seite aber auch sehr sehr große
strahlung da muss man als geneigter
mensch der elektronik heutzutage nutzt
wirklich aufpassen dass wenn man durch
sein zimmer läuft man sich nicht den
gegen kopf an einem großen strahlen
stößt der zufällig gerade durchs zimmer
schießt leute da bitte ich wirklich
aufzupassen
positiv wirkt jetzt auch langsam sein
lassen ich versuche dich ja zu verstehen
würden nicht korrekt verlieren dass er
jetzt ihr so abweisend ihr gegenüber sie
tut wirklich was sie kann um sich vor
der gefährlichen strahlung zu schützen
leute was sie was nicht ganz verstehen
muss ich sagen das gemälde an der wand
ist komplett ab gegangen weil keine
ahnung aber ich weiß nicht ob es die
kleinen oder die große strahlend sind
die bilder kaputt machen sie hat aber
einfach nur so ein schirm brewster aus
alufolie so scheinbar greifen strahlen
von oben an können die nicht irgendwie
aus dem handy raus einfach so ein
gesicht
es geht nicht die kommen aber nur von ok
sowie sowie adler alles klar
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen was strahlen
und adler gemeinsam an das wächst mir
einfach über den kopf hinaus dass hier
das ist zu viel
er ist ein held der leute ist wirklich
so fett an abhängt guck dir mal an leute
ihr könnt einfach nicht sie will einfach
nur eine umwelt schützen sie will sich
vor strahlen schützen großen und kleinen
strahlen die von a wie adler von oben
angreifen und sich auf wieso der adler
auf seine mühlen maus auf die menschen
stürzen deswegen auch sehr gut wie
gesagt und er checkt einfach nicht
gegangen
komm mal klar mach mal auffällig was
sagst du dazu
[Musik]
ok also handys sind unser tod leute ja
ich bin scheinbar ich wusste es bis dato
nicht scheinbar hab ich nicht mehr so
viel interesse an meinem eigenen leben
ich habe mich mein handy hier liegen es
es liegt tatsächlich auch nachts auf
meinem nachttisch ungefähr 30 zentimeter
neben meinem kopf leute falls sich bis
dato schauen meine videos gefragt habt
was ist mit diesem jungen mann los dann
habt ihr jetzt die antwort ich werde
einfach langsam von meinem handy getötet
in den handys die strahlen ja wie jetzt
ich dachte die kommen da raus und
greifen uns an oder je ist jetzt also ja
ich will mich wirklich schützen ich will
mich schützen aber wie wo sind die jetzt
die strahlen sonst große oder kleine
strahlen für jenes scheint
elektromagnetische strahlung eine
bedrohung für ihre gesundheit zusammen
zwar lässt sich das nicht zweifelsfrei
beweisen aber ihre angst ist ziemlich
massiv das kann ihr leben stark
einschränken da meine lieben
einschränken da ist das finde ich gehe
jetzt persönlich ein bisschen zu weit
wir sehen hier einfach eine aufgeklärte
dame die sich um ihre eigene gesundheit
sorgen macht die entsprechend ihrer
persönlichen vorlieben
hier wohnen dekoriert unter anderem wird
einfach so ein drittel der couch wird so
mit alufolie belegt haben als das andere
oder couch nicht nicht schützenswert
leute wobei sie hat damit recht dass wir
alle sterben leute das ist tatsächlich
eine der wenigen aussagen von denen ich
mich anschließen kann
die die an die einzige sache ist ich
glaube wir haben ein bisschen
unterschiedliche vorstellungen vom
zeithorizont also wann das stadtbild
dass wir alle mal den löffel abgeben ich
persönlich will ja denken der masche
junger typ so 25 jetzt der schaft
wahrscheinlich die 85 oder sowas
sie ist persönlich anderer meinung weil
die akute lebensgefahr ist da
ich bin quasi schon ich bin schon futsch
gemacht
ich muss mir was einfallen lassen ich
muss das ist jetzt das problem was ist
denn da federkernmatratze jetzt schon
falsch kann man kann man nicht einfach
mal mehr leben sein leben annähernd
genießen leute wir haben schon schwer
genug zeit aktuell okay wir können alle
kaum rausgehen restaurants hinzu alles
hat zu niger es ist schon hart genug
scheinbar darf man nicht mehr auf einer
matratze schlafen warum weil feder
strahlung rauskommt schließen sich die
federn und die strahlen zusammen und
greifen an
was jetzt das problem
[Musik]
hier finde ich gut finde ich gut dass
sie auf ihre eigene gesundheit achtet
leute irgendwie man sinnvolles argumente
einzubringen ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
nicht ob das überhaupt hier reinpasst
wenn man sich neben der folge an schaut
heute aber ich bin persönlich kein
experte was elektromagnetische wellen
geht ja ich habe keinerlei ahnung aber
es hilft glaube ich immer einen gewissen
menschenverstand anzunehmen ja also wenn
keine ahnung iks millionen hunderte
millionen milliarden auf der welt diese
technologie benutzen und millionen von
wissenschaft man sich damit beschäftigt
haben dann würde ich persönlich davon
ausgehen dass wenn mein handy in sich
die absicht hegt mich dass nachts
abzunutzen mit fiesen kleinen strahlen
ihm in meinen kopf rein fahren dann wird
es irgendeinem aufgefallen seien leute
meine persönliche meinung
[Musik]
sie schleppt ihre matratze aus dem
schlafzimmer raus ja weil sie angst hat
dass die kleinen fehler kerne sich
konspirativ verbünden und sie
attackieren das ist scheinbar
gesundheitsschädlich ja aber als
lieblingssendung ein rtl 2 format zu
haben also darauf hin sich zu freuen
da sind natürlich ein rtl 2 format jetzt
nova und an den sender aber mal ehrlich
leute und das auf einem in alufolie
eingepackten fernseher anzuschauen
das ist scheinbar die bessere
alternative marschall einfach die
schlauer
dass sie mir in venedig beim karneval
sowie was ist das denn für eine maske
ihr seid morgen bild rausgezogen heute
so sieht der karneval in venedig aus und
scheinbar leute wer hätte gedacht wer
hätte es gedacht dass man die eigenen
schutz der eigenen gesundheit so perfekt
mit karneval feiern vereinen kann dekker
diese frau ist ja wirklich ein genie die
kritik alles hin was ist hier los warum
ist ja alles mit alu folie bedeckt der
fernseher die land würden die bilder
hast du mit dem fenster gemacht gibt
diese gesichtsausdruck leute diesen
gesichtsausdruck kann man auch
heutzutage gerne mal haben weil der ein
oder andere sache die einem so über den
weg läuft im alltag ja wobei ich nicht
ich hab mir dann gedanken kommen leute
meint meint ihr ich kann dieses video
überhaupt noch zuende aufnehmen oder
würde mich vorher die elektromagnetische
strahlung aus meinem taschenrechner
töten ich habe herausgefunden dass ich
krank bin und diese krankheit nennt sich
nennt sich gerade steht und somit
radioaktiven verstrahlung
ok radio hypersensibel und so mit
radioaktiver strahlung und zur
radioaktiv die gabe ja mal die optiker
da ist das wort wir sind wir denn jetzt
von elektromagnetisch zu radioaktiv
bekommen von mein handy weg ins
geheimpläne mich absolut dazu ich habe
einfach atomkraft reaktoren meiner
wohnung und ich weiß nicht was hier mit
ines passiert nennt man den nocebo
effekt nur durch die erwartung von
symptomen treten diese auch auf zb
schmerzen oder eine krankheit genau also
leute was was soll man dazu sagen ich
glaube man kann zusammenfassend zwei
sachen sagen leute einerseits man muss
ein bisschen rücksicht auf den heute
nehmen die so abdrehen weil
irgendwas ist in ihrem kopf welche
emotionen oder so die dazu führen dass
leute so am rad drehen
das kann man auch auf die heutige
situation beziehen irgendwas ist da
deswegen finde ich sollte man klar die
aussagen mache inhaltlich oft nicht so
viel sinn aber man sollte trotzdem die
leute nicht verstoßen sondern sie
versuchen fällt auf einer emotionalen
ebene auf sie einzugehen weil irgendwas
ist da angst was auch gut was auch immer
und andererseits sollte zweitens möchte
ich euch mit auf den weg geben was meine
persönliche überzeugung dieser ganze
sache ist wie gesagt das ist sehr gut
alles auf die heutige lage übertragbar
ich bin der meinung die menschheit ist
in ihrer geschichte sehr gut damit
gefahren experten sachen anzuvertrauen
ja und das ist genau der grund warum ich
heute nicht aber eine schule selber
nähen muss nicht meine möbel selbst
entwerfen muss und auch so eine coole
sachen wie das hier haben kann einfach
weil es leute gibt die sich darauf
spezialisiert haben sie sich damit
auskennt und ich vertraue diesen leuten
auch irgendwo in meiner persönlichen
meinung nach kann man das ganz ehrlich
mit der wissenschaft auch machen aber
die abwehr beliefern lassen dass ich
schon muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden heute findet ihr natürlich
vorgeschlagenes video oben könnte man
kann abonnieren wickelt euch mit
alufolie
wir sehen uns in zwei tagen wieder ciao